We reached a new high or a new low, depending
on your perspective in the United States in
the growth of [inaudible] income
inequality and the 400 richest Americans are
now paying a lower total tax rate, federal,
state, and local than any other income group.
This is based on 2018 data, which has now
been analyzed.
There is a really good piece in the New York
times by David Lennart Leonhard.
I'm not exactly sure how he pronounces his
last name, uh, about this.
And when you look at the, uh, the data and
the visualizations of the data back in 1950,
the top 400 richest Americans paid the most
in taxes when you combined federal, state
and local 50 years later, even in the year
2000, the richest 400 didn't pay the highest
total rates, but it was still a much higher
rate than the poor and middle class.
You still had the very rich but not quite
as rich as the richness.
400 paying slightly higher rates than the
richest 400.
But no question that those richest 400 were
paying a higher total rate federal, state
and local than lower income earners.
And then last year in 2018 the richest 400
actually paid the lowest total rate of any
income group.
Now you might see that.
You might hear me say this and wonder how
is that possible?
Because when you look at the federal tax brackets
for 2018 for example, uh, we see that the
tax bracket is highest at 37% for those earning
over $500,000.
But what you need to understand is that is
that we're talking here about a group [inaudible]
400 that is so far above the entryway to that
top bracket of 500,000 that they have so many
different mechanisms for deductions and loopholes
and exclusions and the moving around of money
on paper that they now are paying the lowest
combined federal, state and local rate of
any income group.
Now let's discuss a common argument that we
hear from the American right wing, which is,
listen, whatever rules you pass, whatever
tax law you change, the rich will figure out
a way to avoid those taxes.
So what's the point?
They'll get better accountants.
They will somehow figure out a way to avoid
those taxes.
This is completely untrue.
Number one, look at the historical numbers
I just showed you, right?
I mean, the rich have historically not avoided
all taxes paid the lowest rates they used
to pay more than lower income brackets.
So historically we know that that argument
is bogus.
Number two, Oh, and I should mention, we're
talking about the very, very rich here.
We're talking about the richest 400 the richest
0.1% we are not talking about a doctor making
$300,000 okay?
That's not who we're talking about here.
And it's important to understand that there
is a distinction here.
Number two, historically attempt to collect
more taxes have worked.
We know that when we look at historical tax
collections, and number three, if the rich
could just avoid any new taxes, why would
they work so hard?
Why would they spend so much time and money
and political capital fighting new taxes?
Because they know that they would be affected
by them.
So that argument is a completely bogus and
ridiculous argument.
These are basically just choices to be made
by societies.
And the trick of course, by the very rich
and corporations and the upper class is to
foam that class warfare down below.
This has always been the technique you hear
from some brainwashed right wingers that the
left of the middle class and the lower middle
class, the poor are the ones fighting and
pushing, you know, race warfare, class warfare,
that if it weren't for them, then everything
would just be completely fine.
But understand that this is a technique that
the very rich use look at the battle between
American born restaurant and agricultural
workers and so-called illegals from Latin
America coming here to steal your jobs.
That is a battle that corporate America and
the super rich and the upper class want you
to be having.
Why?
Because if you as an American born restaurant
worker are fighting against the idea of some
hardworking Mexican dad coming here to quote,
steal your job, uh, you are not going to be
fighting the actual people that are deciding
policy and that are controlling the system
and maintaining the status quo.
It is by design.
A another example, while the super rich and
corporate media talk about millennials are
lazy and this and that, it's the super rich
who win by being ignored.
They take the focus off of the fact that the
student loan burden on millennials is astronomical.
They remove any discussion whatsoever of how
the ratio between the cost of college and
the salary one expects to earn has fallen
completely out of whack compared to what it
was 30 40 years ago.
This is all by design and it is really important
that we not allow that to distract us from
what actually needs to be done when it comes
to policy because when we're having the wrong
debate, they win.
That's the, the sick genius of it.
They don't care who wins these false debates,
right?
If you're a big corporation and you benefit
from cheap labor and deregulation of labor
and all of this stuff, do you care whether
the quote, illegals win against the poor American
born white people in the battle around who's
going to steal who's job?
No.
The fact that it's a battle that is even going
on means that you win.
And this is what we fundamentally have to
understand when we look at these numbers.
So inequality, uh, certainly getting worse
and worse, partially on the back of a tax
code that now has the richest 400 Americans
in the lowest total tax bracket.
When you combine federal, state, and local.